we've all heard the narrative apple is
too big amazon is too big google is too
big it seems like these tech giants have
formed unbreakable monopolies around
various segments of the market and that
they're quote-unquote too big to fail
but if history has taught us anything
it's that no company is too big to fail
sure the government and stockholders can
bail out the failing company and give it
another 10 20 30 years of lifetime but
you can only do this for so long and
eventually these companies will fail as
well
just take a look at the biggest
companies throughout history sears
roebuck and co for example is often
credited with inventing the department
store and throughout the 1900s they were
the biggest retailer in the entire world
yet in 2018 sears filed for bankruptcy
and shut down all of their stores
similarly chrysler and general motors
were two of the biggest names in the
automotive industry throughout the 1900s
yet in the late 2000s both of them filed
for bankruptcy now of course these guys
got bailed out because they were
integral to the automotive industry in
the late 2000s but do you think they'll
be bailed out again if they miss out on
the eevee transition
if there's a handful of eb companies
like tesla rivian and maybe even ford
overshadowing them i don't think they'll
be bailed out also if these companies
were truly too big to fill they would
have never needed a bailout in the first
place so clearly all companies come and
go but how does a company go from being
an unstoppable force in the market to
eventually being forgotten about
the first struggle that every large
corporation has to deal with is the
pains of scale we always hear about
economies of scale and i'm sure you guys
know exactly what this is economies of
scale is a cost advantage that large
companies enjoy due to serving a large
market pains of skill or diseconomies of
skill on the other hand are a cost
disadvantage that comes along with being
too big
you see small companies don't have human
resources or fancy corporate events and
they don't fly around executives and
directors around the world
their employees also don't spend hours
every day answering emails or
participating in meetings in other words
smaller companies generally have little
to no operational expenses youtubers are
a great example of this
while there are some creators like mr
beast and good mythical morning with
massive teams and production expenses
behind them most creators have extremely
small operational expenses pewdiepie
wolf athlete next graham stefan andrei
[ __ ] and mark rober are all basically
just one man shows sure they may have a
few employees to help them edit and make
sponsorship deals and so on but compared
to their income the amount they spend on
payroll is extremely small not to
mention it most of these guys just
record in their bedroom or a small set
inside their house
so if they have a bad month in terms of
views it doesn't really matter they
won't make as much money but they're
also not in any risk of losing money the
same however cannot be said about a
channel like the infographic show if you
were to replicate one of their videos
using professional talent it'll easily
cost you 10 thousand dollars per video
but i'm sure they have insane economies
of skill maybe their cost per video is
only three thousand dollars but to get
to that number they had to take on a
boatload of fixed expenses in the last
month for example the infographic show
posted 42 videos and even if each video
only cost them three thousand dollars
we're talking about a fixed cost of
about 126 000 per month given how many
views the infographic show gets every
month i'm sure they pull in way more
than this in terms of revenue but with
that being said their operational
expenses are a much bigger percentage of
their revenue than someone like andrei
jig this means that it would be
significantly easier for andre to wear
their 50 percent down turn it than it
would be for the infographic show this
same principle also applies to the
biggest companies in the world
regardless of how the next iphone
performs apple has to pay tens of
millions to keep the ufo and california
alive they have to pay for tens of
thousands of man-hours spent in meetings
and answering emails and they have to
pay large salaries to thousands of
managers and directors that a small
corporation simply wouldn't need while
these may seem like negligible expenses
compared to apple's profits the thing to
note is that all these factors create
friction and this friction makes apple
slower and slower which gives up and
coming competitors the perfect
opportunity to overtake them
aside from being a slower behemoth
larger companies usually fall into the
trap of prioritizing profits over
innovation
this isn't always the company's fault
per se
the problem is often that they've simply
hit a dead end within their industry
i mean honestly how much better can you
make an iphone or a macbook really all
that's left is consistently improving
the speed and reliability of these
devices year after year and as each
generational jump becomes a smaller and
smaller difference people upgrade less
often which forces these companies to
look for alternative modes of revenue to
continue growth now apple has done a
phenomenal job with all their services
whether that be icloud or apple music
but none of these are new inventions or
are particularly innovative the same
thing can be said about amazon a lot of
logistics innovation had to be done to
get delivery time frames down from one
week to two days to next day to same day
to one hour delivery but how much more
could amazon really push this and how
much more would consumers even care
about that improvement the truth is that
apple has solved the smartphone problem
and amazon has solved the logistics
problem the only step left is to refine
and maintain as long as possible but the
problem is that the top talent is not
interested in refining and maintaining
do you really think the top engineers
are interested in making the iphone
match smaller or removing the camera
bump
no the top engineers are interested in
developing artificial intelligence
leveraging machine learning programming
self-driving cars creating the metaverse
launching rockets and so on and so forth
so as larger companies start to
prioritize profits over innovation the
top talent will slowly bleed into
up-and-coming companies in the meantime
the largest companies are left with nba
businessmen who are generally more
interested in progressing themselves
than progressing the company now i'm not
faulting these guys for prioritizing
self-preservation over pushing forward
the company but whether their reasoning
is justified or not in the end the
company is hurt and this leads to an
extremely dangerous negative feedback
loop as employees care less and less
about the future of the company their
products become less and less inspiring
which attracts worse and worse talent
which then makes their products even
less inspiring if this sustains for long
enough you'll end up like jcpenney wells
fargo atp dish ge etc if we're being
honest none of the employees at these
companies give a crap about the future
of the company they're all there for one
reason and one reason only a paycheck
and when a company gets to this point
it's all but over
when all the innovation within an
industry is gone what follows next is
always a race to the bottom in the
automotive industry for example once
most of the innovation was done toyota
and honda stepped in and made cars
cheaper and more affordable than ever
before similarly once the airline
deregulation act of 1978 passed airline
ticket prices fell off a cliff this is
quite natural as innovation slows down a
given product or service loses much of
its appeal and companies fan bases
dissipate this isn't to say that people
no longer use said product or service
but simply that they no longer take
pride in a certain brand for example in
the late 1800s a wealthy gentleman may
have been proud to get their electricity
from the best provider in the nation
today electricity is used more than ever
before but no one gives a crap about who
the electricity provider is electricity
is just a part of daily life and the
people choose to provide her based on
who's the cheapest not where brand it's
from similarly when was the last time
you cared about where your gas comes
from or where your steel comes from
even if you do care about these factors
it's likely because you care about the
product itself as opposed to the company
maybe you only buy your steel and gas
from one company because you need a
certain quality of steel or you want the
highest quality of gas but in these
scenarios you're not loyal to the brand
you're loyal to the product if a new gas
company came out tomorrow and offered a
better quality of gas for the same price
you'd likely switch in a heartbeat
clearly the same thing cannot be said
about iphones and androids or mac os and
windows right now
these inventions are still rather new
and the people are still extremely
divided on these subjects but with time
people will care less and less as these
products basically become the same thing
something else to note is that many of
these companies have already experienced
this in the past apple for example
nearly went to bankrupt in the late
1990s after the initial pc boom came to
an end and the budget options flooded
the market they had to pivot to the
mobile market to reignite growth
similarly microsoft had a decade of
stagnation after 2000 as they had
already won the pc market it wasn't
until microsoft embraced the cloud and
servers they started to grow once again
if microsoft and apple hadn't made these
shifts it's likely that they would have
already gone bankrupt or ended up like
ibm
i know a lot of people would like to see
amazon go bankrupt but what's ironic is
that the person who is most confident
that amazon will go bankrupt is jeff
bezos in 2018 jeff said quote amazon is
not too big to fail
in fact i predict one day amazon will
fail amazon will go bankrupt if you look
at large companies their lifespans tend
to be 30 plus years not a hundred plus
years and if we think about it many of
the big tech companies that people
complain about aren't even 30 years old
amazon google tesla nvidia and facebook
are all less than 30 years old the two
big tech companies that are older than
that are apple and microsoft and as we
previously touched on it the only reason
these guys are still crushing it is
because they basically became a new
business right around that 30-year mark
meanwhile amazon and google are fast
approaching that 30-year mark and
likewise they've basically reached
market saturation in their main
industries and they're facing more
backlash than ever before similarly
facebook may be the most hated company
in the world and they haven't even been
around for 20 years this isn't to say
that any of these companies are gonna
collapse anytime soon but this next
decade could very well be the largest
and most dominant that you'll ever see
them after all it's just a matter of
time until a company's friction builds
up they start to prioritize profits over
innovation they lose their top talent
cheaper alternatives enter the market
the customer base dissipates and the
company becomes a shell of their former
self and i think jeff bezos says it best
companies have short life spans charlie
and amazon will be disrupted one day and
you worry about that i don't worry about
it because i know it's inevitable
companies come and go
and the companies that are the shiniest
and
most important of any era you wait a few
decades and they're gone and your job is
to make sure that you delay that date
i'd sure i would love for it to be after
i'm dead
[Laughter]
when do you guys think apple will file
for bankruptcy comment that down below
also drop a like if you hate bailouts
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions that
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one